these look like glory holes
[Music]
spend about $150 from a haircut 20 bucks
I don't really show my hair for the most
part I don't even spend much 40 $50 I
have a feeling I'll be good at telling
what haircut is more expensive yeah I
think I'm gonna be really good at
judging people's hair absolutely not I'm
ready to try all right really glad I
washed my hair can you turn your head to
the left both of you so I can see the
size now to the right have the sides
tapered around and then it transitions
into like this fuqua this one looks like
a more precise job like in the back so
I'm going to say that this is the
expensive one and then this is the cheap
one
you're wrong damn it that's expensive
this one is the more expensive right
we got lucky on this one this is the
expensive haircut right here this is a
cheaper haircut right I am oh wow this
is the more expensive one and this is
the less expensive right if the layer
wears $30 without color minus 50 you
should go to his guy you have kind of
have like bangs in the front kind of
things yeah here's what like Pantene if
anyways here is over $100 I was free I
think because of the double layer that
that's more work if they cut you're in
take up my end oh they [ __ ] up this
haircut is more expensive haircut and
this haircut is the cheap haircut you're
wrong
ah expensive less expensive wrong I
believe this is the more expensive
haircut and this is the cheaper haircut
wrong oh okay
i I think I water on more expensive
barely this one is less expensive mine
was 100 you know how many takes a gas
that would feel $25 I have a theory that
the Santa Monica Supercuts is the best
Supercuts the person who dog sits for
Jennifer Lawrence gets her hair cut legs
come Michael angels
yours is very styled nice and short this
is like a very Beatles haircut you know
your hair reminds me of Harry Styles
when One Direction guys I'm really
jealous of your bangs situation gonna
sniff now this is more expensive because
I want this yay oh yeah I'm good at the
boy ones now more expensive less
expensive wrong this one looks like the
more expensive haircut to me and this
one looks like the cheap your haircut
this is the wordsmiths of wood this is
the cheaper one it's the layers that are
expensive 95 I was 20
it's sorry excuse my language man it's
like a week's worth of groceries for me
I spend $20 so I'm gonna just pet the
hair real quick this here would feel
softer and I feel like I'm looking at
wigs is this considered layer um yeah
whether haircuts kind of look the same
okay your house smells really good your
hair smells good but like Whole Foods
good more expensive less expensive
my haircut is the more expensive and her
is the cheap haircut right yeah yes Juan
is the more expensive haircut and this
one is the cheaper haircut right that's
cool
her hair is more expensive because it's
coarser and I feel like her hair is less
expensive because her hair is not horse
mine was eight dollars Wow whoa
cheaper than McDonald's mine was 150 oh
this was trickier than I thought it
would be for those who are spending
triple-digit or near triple-digit I'll
take a long walk on the beach and
rethink some of the priorities you know
one of my favorite haircuts was the girl
who got it done at Supercuts
five dollar uber pool go over to
Koreatown go over to a South Central and
get your hair cut there cuz you're being
fleeced you're walking into these salons
and they're like hands up it's a
stick-up as long as it looks good on you
like it doesn't matter if you spend a
lot of money on your hair was gel
included was Joe including the styling
gel